Uh,
I think collectively we should be all
together at the table much more often
than we are because I think that the
table is a such a magnet for interaction
from the family onto world issues.
Uh,
it's Ford is a conduit to a venue that
we can sort of permeate each other's
thoughts and all that.
So at the table,
beginning with the family and the
family,
eating together to the leaders,
eating each other's food at the table
and maybe discussing,
uh,
the point,
an issue over a nice bowl of pasta.
I think individually we should have a
consciousness of herself,
of her body,
of living well and using food to get
them in a positive fashion.
You know,
using food to give us pleasure using
food to lose those few pounds.
Enjoyably not in a negative negotiation
because I think today food is a negated
a lot,
you know?
No,
no,
no.
Instead,
food is yes,
yes,
yes.
It's the right food is the right amount
at the right time.